all right Gustav probably the best place
to start here is let's just
differentiate growth from growth hacking
and all these buzzwords that people talk
about sure so the growth hacking term to
me the marketing term if you it's kind
of like the new social media manager
okay if you want to make people believe
your work on growth you call yourself a
growth hacker and if you actually work
on growth you call yourself a product
manager working on growth or an engineer
or a designer that's the simplest
definition I think a more kind of deeper
explanation might be that you can't hack
your way to true sustainable growth
mm-hmm you have to invest long term and
the term growth hacking exists somehow
give the idea that there's a one small
thing you can do and just look for that
one thing and then you're done and
that's just not how it works so maybe
the best entry point into this then is
to talk about the growth posts and talk
about how if someone actually might go
about investing in growth so honor where
would you start
yeah you know before I start on the
framework for growth the reason we
actually wrote the post was because a
lot of growth state CEOs come to us and
ask the number one question which is
what does a growth team do and why
should we set up a growth team because
let's be honest it's a relatively new
concept it didn't exist a decade ago and
Facebook was the first to pioneer that I
think as Gustav mentioned rightfully
growth pros don't like the term hacking
because it sort of implies a gut driven
approach so that's where a growth gene
comes into play it is a very data and
scientific approach to scaling growth
and right after you achieve that product
market fit which we call the zero to one
phase to accelerate growth you have to
use a data-driven approach and that's
when a growth team comes into play but
before you set up a growth team the
number one step you need to check is
whether you have strong retention
because too often most companies form a
growth team and then wonder why they're
not growing
well you have a leaky bucket at the
bottom and so the most important step is
retention and so even if you look at the
post the framing is first check whether
you have good retention so you want to
check whether your users that you
acquired in the long term that is
stabled retention which is parallel to
the x-axis and also it's good retention
so for example if you're a social
network and you have less than 10
percent retention and it's stable like
it's meaningless because as a social
network you need to have at least 50 to
60 percent right so it's more important
to also benchmark whether you're stable
retention is good versus benchmarks or
better than benchmark before you start
focusing on growth mm-hmm so gustaf when
you're at Airbnb how did you decide on
that number
what retention number were you shooting
for good question
you like to give the impression that you
did everything right from the beginning
and when I got to having B we were just
kind of like trying to figure things out
so I don't think that that was the very
first thing we looked at we were just
kind to try to figure out where are the
metrics like what are the things like
how does the funnel look like if you
have great metrics and measuring try
kind of use of funnels through a product
it's pretty easy to figure out your
attention rate and it's pretty easy to
figure out what people are dropping off
and where the opportunities when I
joined there and B we were just kind of
scrambling to get all the different
places we had the metrics together and
that's kind of where we started just
like making sure that we're tracking
kind of our user base and our host and
our guest in like one single place and
there was like one single source of
truth that we can all agree on and from
that it gets easier to start measuring
some of these things
mm-hmm and a marketplace I think today
there's a lot of a lot of knowledge
around how to measure and evaluate the
performance of a marketplace I had not
seen a ton of these things before I
wonder never be like almost almost over
five years ago that I didn't know
exactly what to look at so we just start
looking at all the different metrics and
trying to figure out where the
opportunities were now today Airbnb is
quite different than most other products
in that Travel is a very rare occurrence
you travel once maybe twice a year which
means that looking at retention on the
guest
you'll have to wait a long time or you
have to have a long kind of a couple of
years of historical metrics that are not
like that actually in good shape very
often when you start something you never
have a years where in the metrics so
that means it's hard to figure that out
for most companies you just want to try
to figure out repeat purchase rate
repeat booking repeat use of some kind
and that repeat use have to be
meaningful like you can't just be like
oh I send them a push notification that
came back and now I have repeat use
that's not and just the act of coming
back isn't meaningful unless you do
something that gives you value from the
product mm-hmm and so on or when you're
putting data together for the posts what
were those metrics that other companies
use to discern like oh this is a good
use case rather than you know just
checking site yeah I think the most
important thing is a sign of the action
of usage of your product so in the case
of air B&B I mean you you guys tracked
bookings so because that actually shows
you booked a room wherever and be not
just visit at the site in the case of
uber it was a trip completed right where
you booked the trip and you didn't
cancel it
but you actually completed the trip in
the case of stitch fix this is an
interesting one because you know now
obviously there's a lot of talk about
how stitch fix has done amazingly well
but for the first four years they
actually only focused on retention
because they they they didn't focus on
growth because they had organic growth
but they realized that they had a lot of
opportunity to improve retention so
they're sort of not star metric for the
longest time was number of second fixes
in the first four months so what that
means is how often did the customer
order a second stitch fix after the
first purchase within the first four
months because data had shown that
people who did that retained much better
than others so they focused on driving
that so the growth team actually was
really focused on driving number of
second fixes Wow
and so what caused them to wait four
years rather than just like you know
just going for it from the beginning
because if you have figured out how your
product has to evolve to improve it and
then you're much better or scaling
growth because now you know how to
retain them better with the product like
stitch fix you know which is more
frequency than travel because it's not
once a year but at the end of the day
it's apparel right and it's a lot about
style and fit so for the longest time
people still liked walking into a store
one of the reasons why Amazon didn't do
extremely well for dresses they do well
for standard clothes right
and so stitch fix had to get that
element right it was about hitting the
right style and the right fit and if you
just scaled pretty quickly you would
have grown quite fast but you wouldn't
have retain a lot of users and those are
wasted marketing dollars because you
have to go back and reacquire them so
really that metric and that place of
focus on retention is really what helped
them scale and in the process they were
getting a lot of organic growth and in
the last one and a half years they've
actually invested now on growth as well
but only now the you know it's you know
the Northstar metric has probably moved
to number of first fixes but for the
first four years it was about repeat
okay gotcha so I think they certainly
like entrepreneurs in the investment
community have gotten more sophisticated
of last five seven years around how I
think about growth and retention I think
probably seven years ago people were
more obsessed with new user growth and
just like people going top of the funnel
and they have learned that that it is
not everything and is actually not like
even the most important things I think
we've learned that quite a bit when I do
office i YC companies the first two
questions I try to figure out is
basically what is the kind of ideal or
expected behavior how often do I use
this product let's say it's some kind of
like let's say it's like some kind of
retail product like how often I'm
expecting to do this there's an
e-commerce product how often am i buying
this thing if it's a subscription well
it should be on the regular basis if
it's not a subscription I still want to
figure out how often I do it and then
you want it once you have that number
you want and you can get this number by
kind of thinking out from like what is
that you'll use case you can look at the
data and see well how does your most
typical active users or retain users
actually look like and then from there
and this is exactly
we looked at the the most kind of like
typical retain users and what is the
typical kind of when a booking window
like how long does take between each
book each booking and from then you can
kind of come up with like this is the
scale and then after that you figure out
okay how many people fit this scale how
many people actually are able to get to
kind of do it the way that the idea of
metrics suggests and then you kind of
figure out your retention rate so that's
kind of how you start off and you don't
get everything right right away but
that's kind of a good ways to start many
people don't really know what the
expected time yes
exactly these events should be but it's
very important to figure that early on
so this is kind of an easy possible
question for you guys but uh just tools
in general like basic things like what
should someone set up in the beginning
to start tracking this stuff so when you
start you're probably saving your user
data somewhere so you're probably saving
that some kind of hopefully database
that isn't too complicated okay and very
often when startups go a little bigger
it tends to have this data in several
different places it's important that you
have one person responsible for the
single source of truth data yeah the
data that everyone can trust so that
when you're arguing about metrics you're
not pulling from different sources
you're pulling from the same source
that's critical now when you make say
funnels or expert experiments often you
don't have the data storing it in the
same place to store user data so you
might have that in like let's say
Mixpanel or maybe you have your own
events database but but it's very easy
to start with something like Mixpanel
hmm so those are the two places where
you store your data now there many
different solutions as Mixpanel this
amplitude it's a whole slew of them
they're wise yet to my sleep after my
sleep that YC have funded many of them
of these companies but they're lots of
different ones you can try out mm-hmm
segment is one way to try them out at
all at the same time like you can use
segments you can you can test all them
at the same time but that's usually how
people start to start with something
external additional ones are pretty good
right now when they go to scale or mb
many of them build end up telling
something of their own for different
reasons but yeah okay let's dig into
that so at Airbnb at what point did you
decide to roll your own
around this stuff I think when you have
one or two data engineers so you can
spare for this project okay so typically
10 20 and years then you have enough
that you can say I'm going to build this
myself yeah so I think what case of
Airbnb we started saying okay we have
our own date event event database built
our own clients to kind of send data to
that database from different platforms
iOS Android web and now that then you
have to kind of start learning how to
make sure that it is always like
available so not there's a lot of work
that goes into just making sure
available data is always available for
all the dashboards nor they all the
things you need the data for and make
sure that is correct so you have to do
it's been a lot of time on this data so
it's actually quite a lot more work than
you think you can't do it part time but
there are some benefits to to to doing
it yourself when you get the desk it
meant that stage and how big was the
growth team and you guys started
building your own tool so when I started
me we were three people in the girls
team that was excluding performance
marketing there's probably another three
or four five people and we didn't
actually build the first database it was
a separate team but but I think when I
joined we were about 35 engineers and
maybe six three to six months after I
joined we decided that this is the time
to start investing internal tools and
over the next year we basically built
everything that we needed internally and
it wasn't perfect so over the next three
years we made that perfect they're like
but within a year after after we started
we had like all the components that we
needed and that was basically a
segmentation tool that allowed us to
show different parts that would be two
different users
it was an event tracking database where
you can send all the events so we run
queries and look at at these these usage
from from different clients we can do
that from our own data
and then we built the kind of experiment
framework UI so it would automatically
do the show us the different let's say
we'd run an a/b test it would show us
two different metrics in the control
group in the experiment group you know
automatically calculate statistical
significance and power and all these
different things that you need we didn't
have that all in the beginning
so on the very common way people start
is the store the data somewhere and they
have a data scientist kind of in Excel
pulling the data from the different
groups and then kind of figure out if
that's something is it's significant or
not so this is an insane amount of work
what are the things you guys did that
maybe
were too much work too early and maybe
things you saw on you putting together
the posts like you know what if you're
an early stage company and even if
you're a later stage company you don't
need to do that right now this is the
effective stuff to focus on in the
beginning I think one of the mistakes
that people make early is that the role
of using data to inform there so the
company is kind of on the founders in
the CEO like you use one of the mistakes
I see is that as my nine cent question
by my mistakes is he is that data
becomes someone's responsibility who's
like a data engineer but no one else's
and and then you're not really
succeeding because the goal is to use
this data to make decisions throughout
the entire organization and then you
have to make the data accessible and
available and if you start building all
the technology first it's not going to
be hunterson accessible or available
because you have to build dashboard ship
but all kind of visualization things and
that takes a lot of time so the number
one goal is not to build everything the
time on goal is to make it available
accessible for everyone so everyone can
start making decisions and Mixpanel and
attitude is great to start with like you
could give everyone login and everyone
have access like if you can build in
email reports all kind of things like it
can build building day one and just
building an email report from your own
system that takes a while work so like
there are a lot of benefits to start
with something external and I would
recommend most people that yeah and I
think that's probably the single biggest
statement you know we heard as well when
we were interviewing all the growth
experts was you need a common source of
truth which is why you use these tools
or you try to build something internal
if you feel that tools are not helping
you build a common source of truth but
the more important thing is engagement
from the CEO an alignment on taking
action based on data this is not you
know and this is a very difficult thing
for a CEO to do as well especially if
you're a product driven CEO right
because there's always intuition and
there's always data and it's not
necessary that data always drives all
decisions sometimes you want to run
experiments because or you want to do
build things which are not driven by
data and you know but I think that the
CEO that sort of nose or learns how to
balance both
it actually gets the most out of it and
to this day I think the from all the
interviews I'd say then-ceo that really
stood out in that decision making is
actually Zuckerberg at Facebook pretty
much every crowd expert that I had
spoken to who either worked at Facebook
still works at Facebook are now no
longer but used to said that Zack was
very clear when the data came to pose a
question but at the same time if he
wanted a product decision to be pursued
which the data didn't support he was
clear about that as well saying look I
some my gut says this is the right way
to try let's let's try it and in that if
you use scenario B where you're not
using data but you're using you know
some product intuition that you have the
growth team actually works as defense so
say you make a change and the change
probably is slightly more detrimental
than you thought the growth team can
actually discover the impact in minutes
not hours not days and so a great growth
team can alert pretty quickly and
course-correct if they need be so if you
remember the famous slogan that Facebook
had which is I think it's like you know
do think I forgot the exact two thousand
breaking go fast and break things they
dropped the brake things now because
they have 1 billion users and this is
exactly why you can't afford to break
things when you have 1 billion users
well they break things for some fraction
of those users yes so I think that you
as the single most important thing is if
you decide to form a growth team the CEO
has to be aligned it's not the growth
team's responsibility they won't be set
up for success if the CEO is not aligned
and so it's extremely important that the
CEO endorses the goal of the entire
growth team with the company and when
data is surfaced is asking objectively
the right questions and helping
different teams make decisions based on
the data mm-hmm
were there moments at Airbnb where you
guys are like we're just gonna go with
our gut on this one Oh many times
yeah obviously and and here's how I
think about so and this is a great kind
of way to talk about experimentation so
why
you start with the product most of the
ideas you have like I know when I'm
building I know what I'm filling and you
build it and you talk to users you you
build more things and you kind of you
have a good good idea at some point your
product is so complex so many things in
the product that you make it change you
a human cannot fully comprehend all the
impacts of that change will have so
software and metrics will this offer
keeps track of everything so Erin B and
Facebook are certainly at the stage
where if you make a significant change
or a small change on the product then it
will have some impact down the line that
we cannot comprehend or we do not kind
of foresee that that happens so in order
to to solve that you run experiments so
experiments basically I divide the user
group of a and B into two groups a
control and experiment I'll launch to
change you my experiment group and I'll
look at all the metrics that I care
about and see how they how they change
so let's say I changed the date picker
on the MMB website because I have a new
idea to make it better
well I really want to see a search with
dates is going up or down and at that
point you don't really know like we run
this thing called experiment of you at
everybody I think Facebook do as well
where you literally are take the entire
team in an inner room you show a bunch
of experiments that you've been working
on before you tell the results you ask
everyone what to think
it turns out that the room is very often
divided and have different opinions but
that's because making practice Asians
are really hard it's really really hard
when you have such a scale and such a
complex product to know what's going to
perform better or worse for certain
metrics so that's why you need
experimentation
now growth teams tend to attract people
who are very black and white in their
mindset because they can use data hit
other peoples in the head and like you
know look at the data it shows this so
we have to do that that's not a good
approach because it just it's much more
complicated than that like you that that
vision of the company might not end up
exactly the place of the experiment I
take booking.com as an example of a
product that is probably very successful
but not a product that I'm super proud
of to be working for because like if you
experience it it is incredibly in your
face like there's like pop up and those
things goes all over and it's great for
conversion but I wonder if it's
something that like a product designer
will proud of now you can still do all
those things right and still break bill
it really often prod
think Facebook and Instagram example of
something that's very very optimized
very very good but it doesn't feel like
you're like it doesn't feel like you're
being sold things all the time so I
think you can get to a point we combine
a strong product vision you have some
kind of design guidelines or product
guidelines and still use experimentation
and validation to make your decisions
I'm 100% believe you can do both is
there a good example you guys know of
that where like I mean probably Airbnb
where you push something forward and say
like this is optimizing the funnel for
us this is better but I don't know
something about it just like a little
too hacky or whatever term you might
have used where you had to pull back now
I think I think that's what happens but
I think you have to what people that
work in growth tend to do bad is to
explain the purpose of what you what
they're doing so a lot of people that
work in growth let's say you work on SEO
mmm-hmm the board term SEO sounds bad
sounds like I'm hacking Google yeah
let's talk about what is always SEO
there are a lot of people on Google like
all of us that go to Google to look for
answers yeah and if your product does
not show up on those first three links
on Google you're not going to be clicked
on and you're not actually there SEO is
a way to get your product to be one of
those three answers so people are not
you're not hacking people's mind you're
not doing anything kind of abusive by
doing SEO in any way you're literally
trying to help people there on Google
trying to find answers to questions and
if air be offers the best product to
people are looking for vacation rentals
in the world we should be on the top
three results on Google and I think
that's a great example where like you
just have to change the way you talk
about it and people will appreciate a
lot more why is so important to make all
this effort into being on top of Google
another example I can give is actually
Facebook versus Instagram you know
Facebook was actually known for its
probably on the higher end of aggressive
growth tactics in the early days because
when they were building social network
there was no other social network that
had more than 50 million ma use mm-hmm
right so people thought that they would
cap at 100 million right and
they were paranoid about breaking that
paradigm and sort of telling the world
that they can be the first global
network and they did it but you know the
early days there were lots of email
marketing campaigns and if you remember
if you didn't log into Facebook you
would get an email saying somebody
uploaded a photo of you now what are the
odds one log into Facebook to see what
that photos about but Instagram on the
other hand is you know a the team that
founded Instagram is very different
right the DNA of Instagram is very
different and so they didn't feel as
comfortable using all the tactics of
Facebook so that is a big difference in
the growth tactics that the Instagram
grow three muses versus Facebook's
growth team uses even within the same
company so in fact what the when you
talk to the heads of growth in the
respective groups they would say they
said something called heuristics
so there are X set of things that are
okay that Facebook can try but not all
of those things are okay in Instagram so
the rule of thumb they generally use
within each team is don't ship something
you won't be comfortable shipping to
everybody so if instagrams whole DNA is
I don't want to send an email to anyone
saying your photo is tagged then that
won't be something that would be
experimented on right so it has to it
has to also go with the entire flow of
the experience that you envision for the
product and as long as you set those
heuristics for the team people know how
much to experiment in order to achieve
that and what would you tell a founder
who's just gonna get started and they
want to set their own heuristics I think
that the main thing is look every
founder knows what's best for the
product and the vision they're listening
to their users they should definitely
you know set guidelines but also be open
to adjusting guidelines as they evolve
one of the simple reasons for that is
you know as you expand internationally
you may have to adapt your product in
different ways locally that you may have
thought you would never do right so for
example even with Instagram which is
heavily among
women as users when they launched in
Middle East they saw all men and they
realized well you know maybe we should
change our targeting mechanism right
like we for some reason in the Middle
East we are attracting a lot more men
but you know one of the important
elements of the growth team is to have
use the groups that that do user
research when the team was on the ground
they realized that all these profiles
that had male photos were actually women
because people in the Middle East are
varied about harassment so they didn't
wanna close their pictures so imagine if
you don't really understand the product
of the users you you may not be able to
tailor it to local tastes so you may
have to make differences and have you
onboard users so that it's easier for
people to adapt locally so always start
with a set of heuristics but decide what
you're going to flex and not flex for
expansion you may have to adjust certain
things but there are certain things
which you may never want to change so
how do you start building out a team as
your company's growing that follows
these principles where you know that
gustaf you weren't the founder of Airbnb
but you're very early how do you think
about scaling out a growth team so I
would say the most important that will
the typical the typical team within
growth have eventually all those
disciplines engineering product design
data finds and use of research and
sometimes there's a specific just say
discipline like online online marketing
performance marketing SEO there might be
very specific skill sets that you added
to that but that's typically how each
each team look like the very very
beginning and you need engineering so
engineers typically the very first
person a pragmatic manager can't get
much done without engineering ideally
either one of those few people are
technical enough to run their own data
and like it be able to run their own
queries and and analyze data after that
I kind of grow out from there and maybe
a typical early growth team is two and
years in it and product manager one of
those I deal with my manager is very
savvy and understanding and using data
to make decisions and then from that you
kind of add add on the different just
different disciplines that you need
the term growth team the reason most
companies succeed
most companies kind of start the growth
team is because it's very hard to tell a
company that now you're all in charge of
growth I've almost never seen that work
so now you have a couple different
options you either do that and that
doesn't work well you don't have anyone
responsible for growth yeah that's kind
of like IBM starts because you make one
individual or one individual team
responsible for growth and say this is
your area of opportunity and this is
your metric that you're trying to
optimize and that eventually can teach
the rest of the company to kind of
slowly break out into different funnels
and have similar minds that are similar
work works that the similar way that
they're working towards solving those
problems so that's kind of often why
growth teams are called birth teams when
they start and now you can start them
within the product team it can start an
after the prior team my recommendation
would be starting within the product
team as a specific part of the funnel if
you start an asset product team you're
effectively saying that the product team
might not be able to learn growth as
good of the girls team and therefore it
should be a separate organization I'm
not sure if I believe that's that's a
good idea
so my recommendation be within the
within the product team and it needs to
be have the CEO needs to basically be on
board with this idea they have a growth
team that is moving a little bit faster
so you can get a little more than the
rest of the team and the typical people
you get on that team are people that are
ready to throw away a lot of stuff
because you don't run a lot of
experiments they're not gonna work you
want to throw them away when they don't
work people that are willing to try a
lot of things diving pretty fast like
you're gonna do a lot of a small
experiments and is often the velocity of
experimentation that's more important
than the quality of the idea early on
because you don't really know where to
look you just have to have a framework
to look everywhere and then someone who
uses data to to kind of validate which
ideas are gonna work well yeah I think
the single source of debate at least I
heard when interviewing all the growth
experts was actually whether they should
be part of product it should be separate
right actually I would say majority of
them
would agree with you that it's better to
be proud of product but if they had it
their way they wanted to be independent
and report directly to the CEO and I
think the main reason for that like a
lot of the experts cited was the tension
between the head of product and the head
of growth because growth is so
data-driven and if you have a product
lead who is usually not as data-driven
but because they they come up come at it
from the product design perspective then
that can be tensioned second reason for
tension is you know a start-up is all
about growth and so it almost feels like
you know the growth team is owning
growth so what is what are the other
teams owning and I think that tension is
the second tension that teams have and
this tension and types of experiments of
changes that a girl team does versus
what a product team does which is why I
would have thought that being part of
the product team helped stem that but
you know I think it really comes down to
the communication between the head of
product and head of growth because you
could be part of the product team but if
you're not aligned and if the growth
head is two levels away from the CEO and
thus that CEO endorsement doesn't exist
it tends to fall apart and I think the
only company that actually has done this
successfully being independent is
Facebook again right so Facebook is the
only one that is still maintained it as
a separate growth team and from what I
understand there are very separate
accountability metrics and which is why
it works I think it works any structure
can work as long as there's
accountability for each so the growth
team owns the mau NDA you write in
facebook the product team owns the
engagement and retention so it's damn
clear how its split and so I think
whether you're part of product or
whether you're not as long as the
metrics are clearly defined then you
have better understanding and
articulation of who's doing what Hueber
actually had two separate teams they had
a product team and a growth team and at
scale just one and a half years ago they
merged but even when they merged you
know they had different subgroups so it
at Baker who was the head of growth took
over a head of product and head of
growth but the teams underneath where
Ryder driver
marketplace and platform and few other
teams so I was actually curious as to
why there was a ride or driver and
marketplace right and the interesting
thing is rider team focuses on right and
rode the driver team focuses on driver
growth but someone has to make sure that
the supply and demand are matched that
proactively so they were actually
measuring troop efficiency matches
percentage of times and ETA that the
marketplace owned because they that was
the check of liquidity versus rider and
driver will go team so I think it's all
these and that's worked well for over so
these things all allude to the fact that
its what is most important whether you
sit as part of product or not is what is
that accountability metric for that
group and how does it all roll up into
your not star metric and is it clear
because if this overlap it breaks right
it's just a plus B plus C equal to D but
you need to be able to build your driver
tree and sort of give each team the
metric I think what come here
the uncomfortable for a founder is that
at some point you realize that in the
early days you build a product you talk
to a lot of users spend a lot of time
and interacting with users and some
point you got to scale and you can
quantifiably make a lot of decisions by
just testing things and that I can
imagine that being very uncomfortable
for it for an impound er that is just
like a completely a different way of
building product at scale
and that's often why introduction of
growth thinking in a start-up can be a
little bit painful because it just
changes the way you do things you do
things in a very different very
different way and very early on and they
do things quite differently later at a
later stage alright guys this has been
great
so we're probably gonna have to do
around two on this one but thanks for
coming in thank you so much thanks for
having us
you